ان المراكز التجاريه حول العالم تهدف لجذب
السواح وتحفيز الحركه الشرائيه في
الاقتصاد المحلي لكن المراكز التجاريه او
المولات في الشرق الاوسط لا تختلف ببنائها
عن غيرها حول العالم بل هنالك مزايا
اخرى ان المولات في الشرق الاوسط تملك في
رايي جانبا اجتماعيا يختلف عما يمكننا ان
نشهده في امريكا او بالاسواق الاخرى اذ
تعتبر نقطه للقاءات الاجتماعيه وذلك بسبب
توفر المقاهي المختلفه والمحلات التجاريه
بخصائصها الشرائيه لذا من المهم التفكير
في هذا الجانب خلال العمل بقطاع المراكز
التجاريه بالشرق الاوسط وهذه الخصائص
بالاضافه الى الهرب من الطقس الحار صيفا
تساعد في زياده اقبال الناس على المولات
وافتتاح مشاريع ضخمه مثل المشروع مول
العالم الذي سيقام في اماره دبي الذي يمتد
على مسافه 4 ملايين ونصف ك م مربع لانشاء
مدينه داخل المركز التجاري هذا هو المهندس
باري هيوجس من شركه اتش اوكي وهو اخصائي
بارز بمجالات العقارات حول العالم والان
يعمل على مشروع مارين الدوحه في قطر وير
هيجز بان المراكز التجاريه بالشرق الاوسط
تشكل ما يشابه ديزني لاند في البلدان
الغربيه اذ لا يمكن زياره المركز التجاري
في يوم واحد وبالتالي تتعدد الزيارات
للشراء من محال تجاريه مختلفه على مدى
ايام
متفرقه والشرق الاوسط ليس وحده من ينشئ
المولات الضخمه فخلال العشر سنوات الاخيره
برزت هذه المراكز التجاريه في
الصين مثل مول جلوبال كاربون في شانغهاي
الذي يعتبر احدث نسخه من
نوعها تلقب هذه المراه بملكه المولات
واسمها سوباه امبوت التي تحاول ان تبلغ
حلمها بتحويل بانكوك لوجهه عالميه للتسوق
ولتحقيق هذا الحلم العملاق يجب ان تتلاشى
الافكار
الصغيره